okay welcome everyone actually we have a
number of more than one out-of-town
visitors today visiting us taking part
in the conference although this is you
know I'm doing this experiment although
X I didn't get IRB approval and you guys
are the research sub subjects to look at
the attendance at the conference with a
certain intervention that took place
about two months ago no more pizza it's
a little nervous it'd be nice to see see
more more people here on the other hand
it's the end of the term it's it's sunny
out although we have a great speaker and
I think everyone across the program will
find his talk interesting because it's
very much a blend of bio and clinical so
some of you know dr. Reed Thompson who
is a faculty member here at OHSU he's a
physician X a MD PhD and his medical
specialty is radiation oncology and he
informs me that he just learned that he
passed his boards and the boards for
radiation oncology are a lot harder not
only then internal medicine which some
of us David and myself and maybe others
in here took but also clinical
informatics so that those are just
single tests but he had to go through
this oral exam and so forth but anyways
he's he's board-certified now he is
originally from New Jersey
he went to Dartmouth College where he
majored in genetics and biophysical
chemistry he then pursued his MD PhD
studies at Albert Einstein College of
Medicine in New York and did his
dissertation on epigenomic dysregulation
associated with intrauterine growth
restriction and normal aging completed
that in 2011 and then went on to do
a medical internship and a residency in
radiation oncology at the University of
Pennsylvania he was then the candidate
who was recruited for a position that
was created at the Portland VA the
aiming to leverage the million veteran
project which is another one of these
kind of establish a million patient
cohort projects and and collect all
their data this one obviously having to
do with veterans and so he has a faculty
appointment primary appointment in
radiation oncology he's also involved
with computational biology program at a
Margules program and also a member of
the knight Cancer Institute so he's
going to speak to us today on
informatics and radiation oncology and
the million veteran program yeah so
thanks Bill I've seen every can hear me
I mean in this room but presumably
listening remotely as well I'm going to
try to keep this broad and really
hopefully most relevant to interesting
to a kind of a broad informatics and
kind of more clinical informatics
expertise I hope I'm not dumbing
anything down if you want me to fast
forward do anything please feel free to
be like okay move it along read but I
mentally feel free it's got me along as
well if you guys have any questions and
want to dive into anything further I
won't be be discussing too much about my
ongoing work right now and some of the
genomics products I'm pursuing but I
wanted to keep this kind of broad view
and focus on two areas the racial
ecology in general and then the million
veterans program which which bill just
mentioned so I have nothing to disclose
and this is the quick outline for my
talk today actually you know I'm
clicking here I should use this guy so
first off I just want to touch upon what
is racial ecology frankly I'm
embarrassed to confess that I think a
lot of other doctors you know
board-certified in whatever their
specialty is don't know what racial
ecology is so I'll give a quick primer
and go into some of the more informatics
components therein we're not going to
belabor this at all but when we talk
about radiation oncology we're thinking
about
x-rays and gamma rays which are on the
far end of the wavelengths in terms of
the electromagnetic spectrum and these
actually we can use interventional II
the reason why we did interventional II
is because when you actually have an
x-ray you can direct it towards the
target and you could actually elicit DNA
damage directly from the x-ray itself
breakage other kinds of changes to the
DNA and you could also have indirect
action of the X rays where you can go
towards a target but it actually elicits
radicalization of the the water
molecules throughout the cell and then
those themselves can actually damage the
DNA so one way another raishin can cause
DNA damage and that there aster causes
localized cell death oxygen itself is a
very sensitizer to actually fix that DNA
damage as well so you may not completely
kill a cell but you can certainly damage
it irreparable and at some later point
that that cell may may then die unable
to divide I'm not gonna go into too much
else about the reality in terms of
radiotherapy broad categories while we
can deliver radiation from multiple
different ways one broad cat or we think
about external beam from the outside
going in and in the second category here
this brachytherapy that's basically from
the inside out where you have a
radioactive source it planted or
instilled and that been releases raishin
from inside the body versus external
beam where you have this big kind of
machine over here where you can actually
deliver the radiation kind of like a
flashlight a very fancy flashlight
there's different types of rio therapy
that could be used electrons photons and
various particle therapy and i'm not
going to go into the physics of any of
these either but fundamentally they have
different properties that allow us to
deliver the dose to areas of interest in
different ways such that we can spare
the normal tissues while still targeting
the tumor i can go into more of this in
a second so in terms of again broad
thinking about racial oncology well we
we touched the lives of over half of all
cancer patients it's a very important
modality in cancer care the other ones
of course being surgery chemotherapy and
some other types of interventions and
again we touch upon cancer patients
lives at all aspects of the cancer care
new adjutant lee meaning before
their intervention before surgery etc
accurately meaning after some sort of
surgery or some other intervention
definitively meaning we just go
radiation alone or radiation with
chemotherapy and then palliative lis
meaning that you know we're not
intending to cure anything here but we
can still help with pain and other
symptoms and again all ages so cancers
from young to old and occasionally we're
talking about multiple courses now
whether that's because one person
develops multiple cancers or because
maybe a cancer comes back you need to
retreat or because there's some stage
process to things and we even treat
benign disorders as well that includes
keloids you know kind of like a
hypertrophic scar often happen to ear
but in other place of the body and
multiple other benign disorders that can
it be helped with radiation and there
are relatively few contraindications
duration alone but there are certainly a
list one of them is early pregnancy we
don't want to radiate for a pregnant
woman if we could avoid it
scleroderma is a an autoimmune disorder
that basically makes Rach complications
much more severe so it's kind of like
one of those rock and a hard place
situations in terms of then what we
actually do and again sorry for the
prior but I hope that it'll help to
understand kind of what comes forward it
involves mobilization such that we can
essentially treat a patient the same way
each day right so this is a multiple
treatment regimen that may happen over
multiple weeks every day that the
raishin needs to be targeted
specifically to the same spot and we
need to make sure that every day of the
lines similarly and so we also then
sohere's analyzation it's a picture like
a mask here's the whole vacuum apparatus
that can be used to immobilize someone
there's multiple other different
varieties of all of this and of course
we do tumor delineation via imaging it's
a very imaging heavy specialty we use CT
MRI PET scans and we actually use
tattoos and various markers to help us
kind of align bio lasers where on the
body surface we're looking at so
essentially we take scans with
immobilized patients and then we do
planning on top of those scans such that
then we can implement the plan each day
for a treatment briefly we want to
delineate the the target volume what we
call
the GTV or the gross tumor volume it's
basically what do you see what's still
left there behind if it's after surgery
is there any residual disease the CTV is
essentially the clinical target value
meaning we want to target microscopic
disease anything that potentially is
extension from beyond where the tumor
was or other areas that we we fear that
it might have spread to that we can't
see with imaging and then the PT V is
basicly a planet or planet planning
target volume which allows us to account
for setup uncertainties right maybe
we're pretty good about lining things up
but like it's a millimeter or two off
and we have that tolerance that
threshold that we incorporate into the
volumes themselves such that you know if
we kind of miss a little bit one day
it's not going to be a problem to the
right here we're just looking at a whole
bunch of structure this is an axial
cross-section of a CT this is actually a
sagittal cross-section of CT showing
different kind of numbered structures
here at anatomy quiz I'm not gonna go
through quizzing now let's say like
here's the brain here's the brainstem
the spinal cord etc and these are these
are structures that are obviously not
tumor these are normal but we want to be
able to protect them from from the
radiation as well so then that comes to
the treatment planning we basically make
sure that we delineate what are the
structures want to protect the various
normal organs and then we also want to
make sure that we're focusing on the
areas of disease the GTV CTV and PTV
that I mentioned just before after
you've actually segmented everything out
in an image and this is done often
manually then you want to make sure that
you you do the planning properly which
involves some complex cost calculations
in terms of optimization and you know
depends on the modality etc so you can
have all the different modalities I
discussed before and we think about how
one mate benefit for the other in terms
of dose vector deposition to allow it to
target the tumor while sparing the
normal organs and there's varying levels
of complexity it could take quite a long
time to do these plans and it's like
revision it's iterative and often as I
said it involves multiple plan
comparisons it can certainly involve
multiple patient specific devices
meaning that we might need to build
things that allow us to deliver the dose
in such a fashion for a patient
and again it's very customized in that
sense and even during a patient's
treatment we may need to a find that
maybe
shrunk significantly and we want to
actually be planned so this is adaptive
process that may be required during a
treatment okay and then finally in terms
of you know the broad kind of radiation
thought is just about side effects and
what is the effect of radiation well
certainly the easy one to think about as
well what kill tumors and let's get rid
of them okay that's that's a given but
it has there's a cost to that and as a
side effect cost based on whether
raishin goes to normal tissues now
there's early side effects that could
happen during treatment days weeks
afterwards and there's actually late
side effects ratios often the gift that
keeps on giving and so we see in terms
of our patient experiences that you know
decades later they may have an side
effects from radiation
there's deterministic which means dose
dependent fashion in terms of the side
effects and sometimes sarcastic where
there's no threshold a stochastic side
effect is actually like a secondary
malignancy where you can have a whiff of
radiation and cause a secondary
malignancy another tumor it's not really
a dose threshold anatomic variability
obviously different aspirations in
different parts of the body do different
things and these risks are modifiable
based on whether or not the patient had
concurrent chemotherapy or there's some
underlying you know genetic conditions
or precisions that allow them to be more
sensitive to radiation and then overall
this kind of thought after the patient
has done treatment we really want to
carefully monitor how these patients
heal and how they do over time and it's
a very multidisciplinary approach often
to prevent these toxicities
there's preventative measures such as
like different arm exercises for for for
mobility that can be done or lymphedema
some therapeutic massages and also
surveillance both for recurrence and new
primary and also for watching out for
from these late appearing symptoms okay
so that's a quick run-through of kind of
what reiation oncology is what we do now
I want to go into some more of the
informatics aspects of kind of what
raishin how just think about and
hopefully this will prove somewhat
illuminating so I'm not going to bore
you with what a fox was I think everyone
here probably knows but just make sure
we're starting from the exact same place
we very much think about individual
areas on a scan when we're thinking from
region ecology perspective and why well
you know okay we have a resolution thing
let me just skip the slide because
structure is
composed of individual voxels and so in
here we're looking at axial cross
sections of a CT this is in the pelvis
this is actually in a male we're looking
at the level of the prostate here which
is outlined in yellow and in a lighter
color here you see the rectum these
structures you know are deleted by hand
and they're composed of interval
individual docks holes and we're
basically just creating boundary States
to say what's inside versus outside of
this structure here is a structure
magnet quiz on what it is but it's kind
of a into outlooking view of the
mandible anyway that's a 3d
reconstruction thereof but we use all
those different voxels to then think
about where the dose is going and so
what does it dose regular dis crit is
essentially a oxidized image or an image
that is composed of information about
where the dose is going rather than it
being any kind of anatomic information
this rainbow kind of color wash thing is
looking at a function of dose high doses
red low doses blue and we see here
throughout this body it's essentially
similar cross-section of what we're just
looking at before into the structure in
the pelvis here we see there's a really
hot spot here going to the prostate and
then there's you know we Xperia Z round
in order to calculate this so-called
dose volume histogram is essentially we
have quantitatively assessing where the
dose is going to a given structure you
take that segmented structure and you
say okay well what within that dose grid
what dose is actually going there and
then you can add these up based on you
know point and polygon kind of
calculations here about what pieces the
dose grids fall within that that delayed
polygon you then
yamo skip this you then basically take
the histogram of dose deposited within
that structure and you can do a
differential DBH here and you can also
get this thing called a chemo dvh was
actually much more interpretable for
clinician and it tells us kind of more
about how things are behaving basically
just by by bidding each of these but is
integration so essentially you add this
one to this one you see here as it
stacks up right so essentially you have
low dose up here going up to high dose
here essentially what this says is that
volume is on the y-axis right so you go
to 100% volume by the time you add
everything up and this is looking at
from the x-axis we're the highest doses
received very very little or sorry the
highest very very little of the
structure a low volume is receiving the
highest doses whereas pretty much one
pretendin structure is receiving zero
dose hopefully that's kind of intuitive
but essentially you know these curves
can differ depending upon where the dose
is going within a given structure and
when you add all those up on different
structures here plot it again dosing the
x-axis and volume this is no relative
volume because considering every
structure may be different size you see
these kind of little spaghetti d th's
and ragin colleges are trained to look
at these and think about well is the
dose going where I want it to go and am
i appropriately sparing the the organs
that I'm worried about
to prevent toxicities okay so we
interpret this and I'm not going to go
into details right now but there are
pros and cons of this approach the pros
are those quantitative Interpol's I
mentioned that you can do toxicity
prevention uses for plan optimization in
fact they use it iteratively for plan
optimization but there are significant
cons to this approach as well one is
that it's only a single snapshot in time
in space right so you did the plan you
took a picture and now we're calculating
all the stuff based on picture but
there's a patient to be now you may
change slightly they may be moving a
little bit so it's not an exact
representation and then the other thing
is that it disregards anatomical
heterogeneity what do I mean by that
I'll get that in a second
so first on the kind of robustness
vector so rather than now looking at a
single line you can look at a robustness
plot of these DV HS right so you have
this blue curve this red curve here
these are the targets these are organs
that you want to spare and ultimately
why or why is there more variability
here well essentially what's being done
is you're doing the tick to plan now
artificially move the patient and
millimeter this way millimeter that way
right you could do this in silico we
move the patient slightly and then you
see how robust is this plan do things
change significantly now if you're in a
different position and the answer is for
at least for these organs yes they're
changing pretty significantly whereas
for our target structure again keeping
in mind that we built a PTV right to
account for the motion for the deers or
bus miss it's pretty darn good but it
you know it captures what I was just
pointing out that there is variability
and that you know you can look at single
but really that belies the fact that
there may be some variability and to the
point I mentioned that there can be
anatomic variability well the maybe this
picture isn't the best one to
demonstrate but these are Hart doses all
pretty low it all pretty acceptable but
in this case here the led right it's the
vessel anterior to the heart it's very
significant for fee and according blood
supply the radiation there can really
stricture the vessel and cause
significant coronary artery disease
later on there's significant differences
between these plans depending upon kind
of we're not just running through
quickly but here's the heart and in the
black outline and the LED is kind of
this great area and we're looking at
kind of an on Foss view of a beam where
this box is essentially kind of what
we're treating and you see that the LED
is significant for the LED is getting
significantly less dose than in either
of these plans and so there's
significance aware that dose is going
right the heart overall is just a bunch
of blood there's some valves and things
but there are specific structures
therein that may be more sensitive okay
I'll leave it at that clinical imaging
obviously based on ecology as a
discipline that requires imaging in
order to be able to to make decisions
and so this is just a quick run through
some of the imaging that we're working
with the CTSA and the same as a planning
scan that I was talking about during a
bunch of images but actually during
planning we could actually do sometimes
a 4d simulation meaning that you
actually had the patient freeze and we
watch and see how the anatomy changes
with breath that's not only just in the
chest so that's most significant but
that could happen and there's changes in
the abdomen even we also take MRI images
pet images various other scans and
things that you can do in terms of mr
SPECT etcetera to be able to visualize
other aspects of the anatomy that is not
just appreciate on CT scan and we
incorporate those or merge those in with
our CT scans and we also have
verification scan this kind of plot here
is just showing over time where we take
multiple time points so every week the
patient's getting new scans we're seeing
how things are changing there's a lot of
imaging generated in race oncology and
news bi-racial oncology on top of that
there is more structure so I mentioned
structures these organs that you want to
farewell all these are Glen aids so now
you have all these scans with all these
structures donated here's a 3d
reconstruction of those structures
themselves we're seeing a ton of data
there's a treasure trove this is a maybe
a quick side note but there's certainly
differences I mentioned that the
structures are generated by manual
contouring essentially people contour
differently everyone's got a kind of
different approach of how to do things
so this is basically asking a number of
different experts to delete the same
thing and you see it is variable either
and this look at the esophagus is
looking at actually I don't even know
specifically which different pieces
these are but fundamentally they're
there you know you might get something
slightly different from different people
that's not to say there isn't value
there there's a lot of data there's
actually I should generate this plot for
the data we have it OHSU but this is
something I just took after from the
last couple years at Penn they were
seeing 2,000 in the racial Department
seeing 2,000 new starts a year that
meant over about 15 years based on from
the calculation was talking about there
was about 30,000 patients so that's a
lot of patients with a lot of imaging
data okay I'm going to finally touch
upon emerging topics and racial ecology
informatics and then we'll move on to
the the million veterans program so
automate segmentation by benches that
we're doing this stuff by hand
delineating kind of what's over the
heart is so many things can be done by
computer and more and more will be
seeing this so it's easy to segment out
of the lung it's like it's like I mean a
quick threshold in even is almost good
enough to do that and you could see here
that then a computer could do is pretty
quickly the limitations to be able to do
this at least for this kind of approach
are for soft issues where there's a very
slight difference in contrast changes
playing the bladder for instance is much
more challenging to Delaine to lung via
automated techniques and a lot of
techniques these days don't have any
regard for anatomy so you know sometimes
if you do this clinician you'll see that
many users start falling the bronchi up
to the trachea and you see then the
going out the body and then you see like
the whole lung is the body right I mean
I as an example so we can do a little
bit better when we start getting a
structure specific a lot of segmentation
certainly people are talking about it
more and more it is a hot topic but I
gotta say that there's really no winning
and solutions right now so if you can
account for the anatomy the shape size
location orientation the organ specific
contents so the distribution of council
units what the boundary conditions look
like then we could probably do a better
job and people are trying this this gets
at a second point from racial ecology we
use this image to actually deliver dough
so I mentioned these dos grids well if
you're taking one scan and you're trying
to compare in another scan so in this
case we're looking a fusion of a
planning CT and a rigid pet alignment
right maybe to finish the the patient
was in a slightly different position
when they had the PET scan but when they
had their CT scan and what happens then
is that you know maybe they aligned in
certain areas but rigid alignment
doesn't get everything aligning
appropriately and so that's where what
we call deformable registration comes in
right can you can you take the image and
modify it so now you're warping the
spine so the head tilt works the same
way etc and yes we can get much more
much more close alignment using the
formal registration the problem is that
is difficult to assess the the quality
of that the formal registration is it
artificial or is it actual and and it
can sometimes require manual guidance
there's again no regard for Anatomy at
all it's a mathematical process that you
apply or it's mathematical transform and
the severe caution I point out here is
regarding does this deformation I'll
show this you know you'll see what I
mean in just a second so here is
basically looking at algorithms the
conduction of different algorithms is
like what twelve different algorithms
applied to do this de formal
registration basically just looking at
the image let's warp one image to become
like the other image and so we're
getting a and B aligning if we then
apply the dos grid before and apply that
same warp so now the dos grade is
transferred to the new image the problem
there is that it's not actually
appropriate you see here kind of these
weird pushes I without going too much
into kind of details here what the thing
is how much the dose is deformed and
this is you know both hot and cold are
kind of bad you want to kind of be a
mill you uh don't want the dose itself
to be deformed in some weird non
anatomical way but that's exactly what's
happening here you could push a voxel
one way or another it matches an image
very well but is that appropriate to
then move the dose some are completely
different answer of courses no
so this is where it becomes dangerous
right you get an image to look well but
when you actually treat a patient and
you're saying I want a sum from my prior
plans and now we're going to plan what
this new thing had those plans aligned
you might be you might be convincing
yourself inappropriately and causing
harm to a patient okay in in race
ontology like many other fields I would
say machine learning is definitely
coming through more and more this is
just a small example of something that I
was collaborating on at Penn looking at
racial pneumonitis ratio pneumonitis is
a a lung toxicity essentially induced by
radiation and it's just a machine
learning approach to try to predict a
poorly predicted phenomenon you can
basically take in dose symmetric
endpoints toxicity endpoints again we're
following all these patients and bring
in the various dose of metric variables
right how much dose is the one receiving
etc as well as various clinical
variables what ethnicity are they what
age are they yadda yadda yadda and try
to come up with some better modeling of
an explanation for who is good or
prediction of who is going to get
pneumonitis or not which is of course
important and then lastly there's radio
mix which kind of is a play in quotes
here it's definitely newfangled but
quite important the idea being that you
know there's molecular information
captured within an anatomical scan now
our eyes may not always be tuned to or
trained to detect this but it's
certainly a reflection of the physiology
the metabolism the protein and
ultimately the genome and how much
Yorkin capture in a given scan is very
much question mark but we're learning
more and more that we actually are able
to capture some stuff that we didn't
realize we could basically imaging
reflects biology that's kind of died
positive but some that we've also found
and I don't say we meaning me I mean
kind of the field broadly so a quick
example that I've radiomics right you
can basically take a bunch of different
lung cancer patients you can
automatically segment out the lesions
here these are now boxed off in green
you can apply feature extraction all
sorts of different things you can do
we're not going to go into the details
and then you could ultimately say okay
now we have this grid of realist
features for a given patient and it
could be again spatially aware but you
can correlate that with gene expression
or various clinical data survival other
things gene spreche in meaning
are you up regulating some pathway etc
and so here's a basically a grid where
you have patients on one axis or the
heatmap right patients on one axis and
the other is just a whole bunch of rios
features this is poorly interpreted
Belen general but it breaks down into
kind of three clusters what they're
finding regardless if they actually take
something for yogic features and say
let's apply this to a cohort of one
cancer patient and say how well does
this predict survival actually the
radome x-ray on neck details alone just
looking at the scan take a picture tells
you actually give a split a
statistically significant difference
split in survival for lung cancer as
well as head and neck cancer which is
kind of crazy
so there's definitely something about
capturing biology there yes what is
example sorry say it again
so a pram easy parameters are the shape
the size right that kind of thing
there's these things which are
completely uninterpretable like wavelets
which is a Fourier transform of an image
right to deconvolution essentially and
you're saying you know can we interpret
more that's there is there some sort of
kind of repetitious pattern etc there's
hundreds of features that you apply and
there's dictionary that there are
different trionic techniques and who
knows what the heck one given thing
actually reports on but it's more than
the eye can see I'll leave it at that
okay lastly just to get you guys
thinking a little bit clinical
informatics opportunities in race
oncology there's certainly plentiful
there's interoperability of various
clinical systems right we use all sorts
of different treatment planning software
that's not your kind of standard fare
certainly it's not ethical that we use
epic routinely and and deeply for all
the charting of notes and thoughts and
toxicity management but all of the DOE
symmetric stuff is completely in a
different system and so the talking of
one to the other is definitely an
ongoing challenge moreover this is just
something even more simple this is
looking at just the DICOM RT which is
basically an enhanced DICOM object which
allows you to store reiation information
as well
we don't even put that data into the PAC
system afterwards so you know patient
might have gotten reiation treatment we
have all the plans but now some other
doctor whether it's in the ER or
otherwise is saying okay well I'm
looking at this and I can't actually see
the plant
where the raishin went oh I know they
got radiation but where the raishin went
is something very very important
actually that has a bearing on even
determining whether or not a patient's
pneumonitis for a radiologist so these
kinds of things are actually very
clinically relevant we don't even do
that so there's opportunities for sure
there there's also opportunities
actually at the level of treat and
planning systems in terms of script
ability being able to do automated
planning do some of this kind of stuff
that I was talking about in terms of
automatic contouring yada yada and image
processing there's certainly a need to
touch upon this but deep learning a
various segmentation tasks can we can we
define predictors of clinical outcomes
etc you know the no duration colleges
also just pass those boards so and I
would just ask what might you envision
it's a million-in-one things you could
do with this and want people doing
things but I I imagine that you don't
get much exposure to what we do nation
ecology we're often kind of lost in
another area I I think it is very
relevant what we're doing we're doing a
lot of information okay I'm not going to
do a sum right here so the million
veterans program changing complete gears
the reason why I want to first one this
one is in part because that's why I'm
here and here being OHSU in the VA and
and more importantly because it's
something that I see really is an
opportunity moving forward right now
there isn't anything we're doing with it
fundamentally right it's it's still
something coming down the pipe but I
think it's exciting and I'm excited to
talk with you guys about it
so opportunity to the VA well there are
many but it's an enormous integrated
database over 8 million veterans lots of
hospitals and clinics lots of
longitudinal data in the morantz
certainly comprehensive health
information labs imaging yada yada yada
the million veterans program
specifically right was designed to to
recruit a million veterans get their
genomic data and monitor them over time
right observational study and capture
all their clinical data as well so it's
a massive by report story ultimately
about the creating with genome scale
genetic data and expensive phenotypic
data
I say extensive in quotes actually I
didn't put that in quotes there but it
not everyone is going to have extensive
data fundamentally and the really
exciting things actually there's a
recontact potential mean that all these
people who sign up actually if you find
some cohort identified from the
genomic data you could actually then go
back this is theoretically for the
moment but you can go back and then
contact these people and say off on a
survey or follow up on some enrollment
for another study and there's slight
solar in the country and we're
definitely one of them and we're
actually well like the gold star
recruiting sites which is pretty awesome
so the data captured within the MVP is
it's fairly extensive there's this
baseline survey it's like fifteen or so
ten pages exceed the other ones longer
about 70% of the veterans who enroll in
MVP actually a completed baseline survey
which asks a whole bunch of stuff
demographics you know age gender
ethnicity et cetera physical features
their height weight skin tone hair
handedness uniformed service exposure
right so they're military branch the
combat history they're stationed meeting
with a Asia Pacific where else right
their activities and habits exercise
drinking the health status so wellness
medical history health care utilization
family history and here's just one snips
one snapshot of a page from this intake
form and you see various boxes and they
ask them questions right you know does
your health now limit you in these
activities if so how much modder
activities such as and it goes on to the
whole check boxes of things so it's a
way of getting structured information
about some of these kind of otherwise
fuzzy and hard to assess patient
reported kind of points and this is that
baseline so clearly you can offer
additional services follow-up etc
there's also this lifestyle survey which
about 55 percent the cohorts completed
and and that includes personal
information personal habits something
similar types of things to what on the
baseline so these dive into a lot more
details so for instance here dietary
habits which is kind of one of those
last bullet points right this is looking
at for each food listed I mean who's
conclusive kun could complete this and
accurately I don't even know but but
mark the column indicating how often on
average you have used the amount
specified during the past year and so
here's for dairy foods skim or low-fat
milk ins like two to four ounces per
week yada yada yada so it really goes
like into that level of crazy detail and
55 percent of complete a survey I cannot
tell you I've not access the data I have
no idea degree of completeness and you
know when you start doing a completeness
thing you also do it like bias and
missing this and is that a random but
you know the that's a whole other can of
worms fundamentally there's a lot of
potential to really capture some deep
data therefore
lots of people this got rotated it is a
flub from going from Mac to PC excuse me
but basically this is a I intend for you
to read upside down basically this is
describing the the data set for the the
array itself so that the large majority
of patients are going for a genotyping
array rather than actual exome
sequencing or or even whole genome
sequencing but there are both of those
happening with the color as well to make
it cost-effective they're there most of
the patients are actually most veterans
are actually getting this this kind of
custom axiom array and this is basically
to subscribing
some of the things that are that are on
there there were a lot of v8 specific
things they wanted to enhance so for
instance like this like chip thing which
basically is like a way of assessing
genetic predictors of psychiatric stuff
they're just PPS DS and stuff in there
they they want to enhance the
african-american kind of normal variant
cohort they wanted to add other
quote/unquote clinically significant
markers as you look at the clinical use
and stuff it's for a lot of diseases and
things that are very relevant to the
veteran population but they actually
have a pretty good cohort of interesting
genes the the problem with this is of
course you know you may have users
looking for a single step for gene you
may miss kind of a lower variant in the
same gene you never email tech that so
it is one of those what's under the
lamppost kind of searches the whole
exome and whole genome data is very much
looking more broadly at what's outside
of the light right which is which is
often where those interesting biology as
well but most of the data can find here
this is actually a very quick early
snapshot from when they've got like only
70,000 now they're well over 400,000
patients enrolled but but basically this
whole pliers are showing it there's
fairly good representation of the the
MVP enrollees from those the current MVP
sites like those who could potentially
enroll as well as the VA database
overall so it's relatively good
representation one kind of aberrancy you
have here is aged 60 to 69 patients
where a higher proportion of MVP
enrollees I have no idea why this is or
if we continued to pan out but it's
something that's certain
they're watching and very importantly
they want to make sure to try to boost
the actual female courts so I think over
time we're going to see this plot jump
up a little bit you have a question it
is it is a song actually gets that uh
nope not this next slide I'll get to
that in a slide or two but but um but
you're absolutely right it's actually
boxed off separately at the moment right
it's a whole step replication process
like I I sit here standing before you
speaking about the NBP literally not
having seen a single shred of the actual
data beyond to some of the summary
statistics and stuff right
the only way you get access to this data
is ultimately to have one of these like
pilot projects which they're they're
starting to go through right now so
before I even cane your pilot project
2015 they have a first ran like an alpha
study basically saying here dive into
this data we offer no promises about how
you're gonna be able to navigate etc but
let's see what you do with it and they
took four four specific products that
we're looking at one is on
cardiovascular risk looking at obesity
liquid levels kidney disease multi
substance use and metabolic syndrome
these are all very common kinds of
things that happen certainly the veteran
cohort there's obviously some overlap
there with the metabolic syndrome and
the core vascular risk and even the
kidney disease a little bit right
because that's always a hypertension etc
so it's not these are even completely
separate studies but they said here a
bunch of teams this is interesting this
is exciting
let's see what you can do I don't know
there's anything to report from any of
these at this point but these are
certainly ongoing and then they actually
in 2016 had another pilot round and this
is diversifying a little bit more we
can't go for illness PTSD schizophrenia
and bipolar and macular degeneration I
feel like they're like seems like this
is like metabolic etc and and maybe some
of these substance use and this is more
like a psychiatric at a nos or something
but they definitely are starting to
branch out and actually just release the
gamma round which which is you know we
have our fingers crossed that maybe
other things like cancer and other
diseases that pop up in that because
there's a lot of other things that we
could be asking those cohort on
exploring but it's still not completely
prime time more to Christian say about
the the the the mechanism of storage etc
this whole environment they free
to be able to kind of not only do the
intake but also do some of the
processing and so this is the thing
called Genesis such as a whole separate
system to do the recruit and enroll this
is a form from basically the recruit and
enroll procedure so a rolling site can
basically say okay why had the patient
say in front of me they they ate you
know seven hours ago and here's a blood
tube of print the barcode they draw and
they send it off that's basically it
there's more to it but that's that's the
large bulk of that part and then there's
this whole other system here which
things feed into essentially for the
scientific environment the idea being
that the MVP data will be able to talk
to the CW which is the clinical data
warehouse and and and and and be able to
merge these in once you have access to
the MVP data so they will be that
ability to talk but otherwise you can't
you can't you can't you can't access the
gear from the CDW and they basically
create a whole remote mouse environment
to do this there's software that you can
use on there or SAS yadda yadda yadda a
customizable you put other things on
there as well they have a bunch of
saying at scratch space and it's they
actually have provided a 192 node
cluster to be able to do some the
compute and actually a partnership with
goe to really kind of ramp up as things
get going
and there's third party knowledge base
integration as well so right can you
pour it in data from the NCBI various
other databases thousand genomes etc
this is a little bit more just kind of
about the complexities of VA CW
structure this was just a cartoon kind
of showing what is certainly a complex
system I actually cannot claim to
completely understand the way they
structured everything but it is complex
and it's definitely divided into regions
so there there's different layers of the
actual CW in terms accessibility but
ultimately one of the port's to actually
be able to ask research related
questions of is through this thing
called Vinci which is through Salt Lake
which ultimately is kind of a research
core to be able to patch into the CW and
they're there to Anneli support but also
to to perform from these analyses so a
lot of the the MVP kind of products to
date are in partnership with Vinci so I
don't need to lecture you go to a data
on top
oh geez but obviously these are
important a lot of the data from the CW
etc is not kind of rich in terms of all
of these already structured pieces and
there's there's obviously a lot that
needs to be derived in terms of NLP from
notes and things that you could
potentially get it as well
a lot of the initial projects are not
diving into that level complexity it's
much more easily phenotyped kind of
topics and questions and this is just a
point about kind of given IV accuracy
obviously this is the bane of a lot of
people's existence dealing with clinical
information it's messy it's noisy yadda
yadda is missing this and so ultimately
can you get really who are the true
cases and who are you missing etc it's
one of the main questions that actually
is now through these pilot rounds in the
VA is how can you really get those good
rich phenotypes out and then once you
have those men you can merge in with the
the genetic data but there's a mess in
the first place and this is an easy
point but we know that sequencing data
is increasing and beyond the MVP you
know just more and more sequencing data
as a capacity to store it and generate
increases we really are starting to hit
those hurdles of doing analysis and I
know that right I I know that it's a
very common denominator for a lot of
people in terms of challenges and so I'm
not going to go into these details here
this is basically just looking at
possible uses of the MVP this is you
know at a very very basic level and and
not even applying it to a specific
disease but pharmacogenomics very much
relevant to actually within the acción
panel they've really focused on a number
of pharmacogenomic lis relevant or elite
that we know of relevant polymorphisms
which may influence you know levels of a
drug etc so pharmacogenomics is a big
deal and we can certainly talk about
that at some length there is there's a
whole bunch of jiwa studies that I
perform some of them I think are
complete
well I won't I won't use a swear word
but not good and an example
I'm not even particularly play out this
so just put the genomics of white wine
preference just to me strikes was very
funny like on its head I don't even
understand that there's a lot more
genomic studies that are that are
I'm increasing and I think as a caveat
emptor but it's very important to do
these analysis rigorously and I think
economy challenge I would ask you kind
of what questions but you think about
asking at the MVP and what kind of
information will be mine
in terms of phenotyping appropriately to
be able to generate the kind of
endpoints that Jeanette Jeanette
predictors that's really it we've
touched upon kind of two broad
categories racial ecology and the MVP I
really did not dive into specifics for
either in in too much detail but I'm
happy to discuss and ask if you had some
questions and I'll take it from there
question and let me ask for those who
don't normally attend our conference if
you ask a question to push the button on
the microphone so the people listening
on the webcast can hear the question my
I apologize if you mentioned this but is
that when researchers work with the data
is it de-identified or or is it not and
recognizing that sometimes when you do
identify data you lose some of the
fidelity of it right so so for the MVP
code specifically you're talking about
yeah my understanding again I've not
worked with this directly is that that
there's separate identifiers right so
you're never actually accessing directly
name that kind of thing they've already
kind of abstracted out I mean you may
have the the the the last for Social
Security as part of the Maran that kind
of thing I know they generated unique
IDs for the MVP specifically which are
linked of course to the the CDW so they
are identifiable but in terms of the
data fields you have access to again I
can't answer from a point of experience
but I believe that they're de-identified
just because actually it's really hard
to to truly be identify and I'm not
necessarily advocating that people
should because when you start the
identifying data you start if you start
changing the ages to age ranges and but
the reality too is though that there you
know especially if there's going to be
text documents going in there to
identify every last piece of identifier
information
you know what you ask I mean it's
absolutely a conundrum and I know that
as part of the you know you're having
access to all the data so theoretically
if identifiable again I don't know to
what levels they've abstracted things
that but you certainly don't have access
to like first-name lastname kind of
stuff at least not explicitly
so that's all included the basket the CW
against this is the point of
identifiability like we can track to the
patient so you say if you know the MV
patient is there you can actually pull
the relevant information from the
clinical data warehouse and that
information may include a raishin
ecology treatment summary for instance
right in order to get the dose symmetric
information well oftentimes as you know
name I mean here at OHSU we actually
treat veterans but we treat them at OHSU
so the veterans are sent across the
bridge all the treatment information all
that plans have is stored within the
treatment planning system at OHSU so
even though the VA knows that a given
patient was treated right they don't
actually have access to at least not
explicitly have access to the treatment
planning information the DBH is that
kind of thing and so Nina's point is
right on some of the facilities in the
VA actually do have raishin internally
and that data again it's probably not
completely or at least expertly
available because they're often boxed
off in treatment planning systems which
are not directly talking to the CDW so
so it would take some legwork it would
not necessarily take a home of the IRB
but it would take a lot of requests and
it would have to be through a tractable
number of patients I think or at least a
sufficiently staffed group that could
kind of follow the dots in terms of
privacy so actually I do have a product
right now I'm sick my fingers crossed
Uno's is going to go through or not
we'll see but looking at cancer
specifically smoking induced well
typically tolling in new cancers for
instance along and bladder in
non-smokers right so is there some extra
genetic underpinning there in those in
collaboration with the group in
northwestern and the figures across who
the heck knows I don't know what they're
looking for but this is going to be data
that continues to evolve and I think is
going to be right for many opportunities
moving forward so you know get you it
gets your brains thinking and and and
certainly we could have we could do lots
of talking about opportunities
it is
yeah III don't have a good answer to at
this point I in speaking with Scott and
again thanks Dave for that you know it
these are one-offs I don't think there's
there's overall class solutions to the
problem and it's obviously a
multi-headed problem so there isn't such
a thing right but fundamentally I I
don't know that they're really that
really has been established I think
they're looking to see how people are
using this appropriately and it's part
of all point to these pilots and I have
not been part of the discussions to date
thinking about what would be the best
structure for that but imagine guys like
Scott would be so you know you point out
of an appropriate need and and I guess
it depend on how I start the phenotype
and how challenging it is I mean there's
some easier phenotypes than others and
some more reliable ones and others so
even if it is implemented at Iowa State
solve the problem for everyone right by
the way on that the the the product was
referring to is one that was a
collaboration with or cousin ars-art did
not go through but we've figured cost
for next time we'll be in touch to have
another round in this fall yep actually
let me ask a follow-up to Dave's
question so you know in parallel with
this is the precision of medicine
precision medicine initiative or all of
us I guess are calling you now there's
also you know all these picori CDR ends
the UK biobank is there on you know
effort across these projects to try to
you know obviously I assume they're all
committed to using the standard
intelligence but you know other ways of
structuring data are there those sorts
of communications that you're aware yeah
so so again I'm not functioning at that
level to be able to answer appropriately
I know that there is a lot of crosstalk
and thought about that in fact to the
point that beyond just even having the
ability to kind of structure information
intelligibly
the all of us co or is actually merging
in some ways with the MVP core
separately but actually recruiting
through the same mechanism of MVP
to actually now enroll veterans in all
of us as well so separate people
potentially maybe one would
- one one with another or maybe they'll
both go die I don't know if there's be
any double dipping but I do know that
actually the CIA is part of that and I I
do think the vision is ultimately to
kind of bring those assets together but
they're very very different data right
the all of us card does not have the
baseline surveys like there's this big
things there and distinct things that
veterans have that other people don't it
it remains to be seen though and I have
some concerns about all of us also right
I mean like it's exciting it's awesome
and all of you guys should consider
going out there and joining and putting
putting your genomic and health
information out there but it you know
how that's all being structured and how
rich is the clinical information is
associated with the Jianghu information
it really is a big DVD
all done to the same group so all the
blood gets sent there's a huge freezer
in Massachusetts where they've got like
4 million tubes of blood like that kind
of thing right like it's very very
standard and centralized I have a
question about I guess kind of how the
data are being collected over time so it
sounds like there's the baseline
questionnaire that they're doing but is
is everything kind of a byproduct of
when they're coming in to receive care
or do they have structured research
follow-up very much the former meaning
that that this is not meant to be an
interventional study specifically
they're just kind of taking whoever came
along and whatever health history they
have up the day I mean literally it's
not enriched or at least not
intentionally enriched for anything
specifically and then as I continue to
have follow-ups at the VA now one of the
things to undermine this unfortunately
right there's this thing called the VA
choice I've know if you guys are
familiar with this but the whole idea is
that veterans are not getting kind of
appointments quick enough and it's a big
political football but fundamentally one
of the solutions from the VA was
actually well we're going to allow you
then to be able to get your care
privately and the VA will pay for it and
so it's kind of decentralizing the the
health records and the health follow-up
and everything for patients I think
that's diluting the quality or at least
the centralized quality of the VA I
think it right now it's not too much
beyond a blip on the radar screen in
terms of the cohort data but that
remains to be seen and and and not every
patient has all of their care within the
VA so there's no specifically structured
follow-ups however I mentioned this
recontact potential I think there is the
opportunity moving forward now that's
not been activated at this point at all
but in the future there is a very
significant opportunity to be able to
enroll patients in like a sub study
potentially or to be able to send out a
questionnaire that focuses on playing
particular based on some genetically
identified kind of flag that you've had
right so it's it I I think this will
give a lot more over menus to Cubs thank
you
okay well thank you guys really
appreciate your time and attention Oh
[Applause]
you
not much
[Music]
you
you